turn now to the corona virus still
raging across the u.s
and the vaccination programs that are
struggling to keep
up hundreds of older people in florida
waited in line for hours over the
weekend hoping
there were enough shots for them nearly
30 thousand americans
have died from covet 19 in the first 10
days of 2021.
our lead national correspondent david
begno is in hard hit los angeles david
good morning
good morning you know here in california
within the last 11 days
they've lost more than 1900 people who
were infected with coronavirus
this morning we're at the la county
coroner's office where they're running
out of space to house bodies
they've set up a mobile morgue and asked
the national guard
to help them move bodies you know over
the last 10 months we've let you hear
from
doctors and nurses and custodians all on
the front line of the pandemic
but this morning we want you to hear
from a chaplain whose job is to be there
at the end of someone's life
and she allowed us to go along with her
sister terry marr is head of spiritual
health at st
mary medical center here in apple valley
she was called to the room of maria
arrieta
around 15 minutes after maria died with
covid
we'll see what we can do for them inside
are maria's children
including her son freddie villegas and
daughter
blanca gonzalez
they say they were told to hurry to the
hospital but when they arrived
their mother was gone
then sister terry does a prayer over
maria
with her children we ask you to
celebrate the life of maria
celebrate her generosity
together they share a moment of grief
and grace
as they say goodbye to a mother and a
grandmother
this is the scene playing out in
hospitals across america
as the coronavirus pandemic continues to
spiral out of control
but even surrounded by sickness fear and
even death
sister terry is still working to comfort
those in need
we give you your servant genevieve lord
this woman of faith
comes to you just it's so neat of air
it's people like genevieve vasquez
who prayed for the breath of life as the
virus
ravaged her lungs we pray this in jesus
name
amen sister terry told us that within
the first 15 minutes of arriving at the
hospital on sunday
three patients coded and every day seems
to be getting worse
before the pandemic she says she prayed
with or
over people three times a week now she
says it's happening more than three
times a day
it never gets easy death is never easy
this is what i feel like god has called
me to do
where god has called me to be and that's
the strength i rest on
for maria's children it's so hard to
lose her
they still don't know how she got sick
she was very precaution she used to
leave her shoes outside
we just don't know what happened maria's
son wanted to share one more message
take the virus seriously it could be
your mom
this time was our mom maria
arrieta was a mother of five a
grandmother to twenty
her family told us she was a woman of
faith who was
unfailingly generous
gail david that was extremely hard to
watch and i was wondering why they
wanted us to see it but you just
answered the question they want us to
know how
serious this is and for us to to wear
our masks that was very very difficult
to see someone
lose their life like that thank you may
her memory be a blessing
yeah yeah